concerns from ccsd staff about violence
in local schools we've shared a couple
of incidents recently but a teacher we
spoke with says this has been ongoing
for some time madison kimbrough looked
into what some say could help stop
it now what's most startling about this
is that social media has brought it to
light now the teacher we spoke to says
that violence at school is nothing new
but they do feel that it's escalating
this has been happening for months and
months
and it's been getting worse and worse
and i always say i can't believe
that it's not out there like so now that
the videos are being
taken and the videos are getting out
there now people are like starting to
pay attention but it's every day it's
every day a ccsd teacher says fighting
in valley schools is nothing new just
recently reports of violent behavior at
both legacy and vegas high school have
surfaced both students involved now
facing serious criminal charges nevada
mental health psychiatrist dr timothy
heider says they've seen an uptick in
children acting out in violent behavior
due in part to the impact of the
pandemic on our end of the there's an
overall larger number but these folks
have been coming to see us for a long
time now so this isn't inherently new to
us but the amount of it does seem to be
increasing ccsd says it's taking these
incidents seriously retired henderson
police officer david colemeyer says
students need to be held accountable we
need to be tough on crime we can't allow
people to just think they can commit
crimes in school because the next step
is using a firearm or using a greater
greater violence in the actual school
we reached out to the school district to
get information on how many violent
incidents have been reported this year
we are waiting to hear back reporting
live from ccsd headquarters madison
kimbrough live local now